HDR or high dynamic range displays
promised to offer a bigger range of
colors and are much richer than normal
monitors they're even called the biggest
leap in the 4k era but it's all just
hype really worth it
[Music]
welcome to hobbies nowadays HDR monitors
are quite common and you can pick them
up for a much less than $200 even it
offers a much wider range of colors and
thus the contrast and richness with
display are significantly improved well
put side by side the difference is
oftentimes quite staggering but how
exactly this HDR work well one of the
core technologies that HDR utilizes is e
OTF or electric optical transfer
function now this sounds really
complicated but it's actually quite
simple basically it is an electronic
value of the content that specifies the
brightness of the display for example a
value of 768 equals 2 nits and the value
of 1,024 equals 5 minutes and so on and
so forth
but it don't all displace do this when
displaying an image when there are total
display color they simply display as
bright as they can
HDR displays on the other hand adjust
the brightness level in order to produce
an image that's much more lifelike
compiler the much wired color gamut this
is the big difference that you're
witnessing when you're comparing
side-by-side
HD displays also produce better color by
using better light LCD displays for
example use color filters which are
essentially plastic sheets these plastic
sheets fell to the white backlight
improves the clarity you see the key
issue with the strategy is that the
deeper the color the dimmer the display
is and this takes a significant hit on
the richness the easy solution to this
is used to color LEDs but color LEDs are
a lot more expensive and even if you
were willing to pay the price is quite
hard to find a TV with the green red and
blue LED lights the substance solution
to this issue is to utilize quantum dots
these microscopic materials are actually
very efficient in creating colors
it is relatively easy to display the
exact frequency of color that is being
required as a result these displays can
produce a very deep color while not
losing out on brightness the main thing
actually hoping HDR to work is the
content itself for the past 10 years the
vast majority of recorded footage
actually has a higher dynamic range than
it's possible to display with the modern
TVs each jar unlocks this extra
potential in Mesa colors much more true
to life even many films are produced
over 10 years ago are currently being
remastered in order to be compatible
with HDR finally as a result is HDR
worth it and should you buy a display
with this technology well this question
is actually very easy the answer is yes
they are definitely worth it without
cheap and common they have become in
just the last couple of years it is
clear that this technology is can assume
become a standard most Netflix shows and
all movies already support this on top
of this if she turn displays will
actually make anything look better due
to their bigger range of colors so if
you can afford it
this is definitely a better idea to buy
display with HDR technology so that
you're not left behind in just a few
short years but that's just what I think
what do you guys think do you think HDR
is the future and if so do you already
have a monitor that supports it make
sure to comment down below what you guys
think also you feed that this video is
helpful the measure drop the like and
consider subscribing if you'd like to
see more videos just like this one
but till then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on next one
[Music]